and so with our video on Galactus being
a resounding success you guys really
seemed to enjoy the idea of Galactus I
thought it'd be fun to go back and talk
about the heralds of Galactus but
depending on what it is you guys are
interested in what I like to do here is
start with the weird heralds of Galactus
the strange heralds of Galactus the ones
that we just don't really hear about or
didn't really expect and the first one
we're going to be doing is of course
Deadpool because why not
if Deadpool is a Herald of Galactus by
God we got to do a video about that
so as we start this video what we do is
we pick up with Deadpool who is
apparently completely broke he has no
money whatsoever he's actually $300,000
in debt 25 of which appears to be due to
the purchase of guinea pigs now I have
no earthly clue why Marvel doesn't
explain that and I'm kind of glad they
don't but what we do is we pick up with
Deadpool as he's basically calling
various supervillains he calls magneto
the Red Skull he calls kingpin among
others I Mephisto Doctor Doom and Doctor
Octopus and what he's basically doing
here is trying to find someone who will
allow him to be a freelance killer for
them basically operating as if he were
Herald although he'd be killing people
much of relation to what we'll find with
Galactus but what he sees is that among
the individuals which also include
apocalypse and Iron Man who of course
tells Deadpool that he's a good guy and
has no need of someone that would kill
for him that they all turned him down
they all refused his advances in terms
of him undertaking the role of being a
killer for hire for them and so what he
does is he gets on his tablet and he
begins surfing the internet and when he
does he comes across an ad that's been
taken out by Galactus for someone who
would be interested in fulfilling the
role of a herald and so what the ad says
is that if the person is interested they
should simply say the word Herald aloud
and the interview will commence and so
what Deadpool does is exactly this he
simply asks himself what it is that a
herald is and because he spoke the word
herald aloud he's he's drawn and by a
Potter I'm sorry by a Galactus he's
brought before Galactus and when he
asked Deadpool whether or not he knows
what it means to be a herald Deadpool
says no and he simply just tells
Deadpool that the entire basis of a
herald is to prepare planets for the
coming of Galactus so that Galactus
going to consume them and so when when
Deadpool says it he thinks it's awesome
and that he wants to know when to start
I'm sorry a Galactus makes his I guess
is implementation in this role immediate
and so he bestows on Deadpool the power
cosmic and so what he does is he sends
Deadpool throughout the cosmos and tells
Deadpool to effectively begin tracking
down various planets and so what we do
is we pick up with Deadpool G's comes we
come across some unnamed planet
somewhere but what happens is that as he
begins killing all the different
organisms on this planet using the power
cosmic he begins to piss off Galactus
then the reason why he begins to piss
off piss off Galactus is because he
won't shut up well he just keeps on
talking
and talking and talking and he's not
talking about anything important he's
just ranting on about nonsense he's just
going on about things that really don't
matter and and galactus just seems to
completely get annoyed to the point that
he ends up I would not would really say
that he ends up killing Deadpool but he
does go as far as to say that if day
that if Deadpool doesn't shut up that
he's going to end him entirely and so
effectively dead me Deadpool has been
fired as The Herald of Galactus which is
a pretty entertaining when you think
about it pretty fantastic but
nonetheless so Deadpool retreats back to
back to the planet Earth but on the way
he comes across a Silver Surfer and the
Silver Surfer says the Deadpool's caused
enough havoc for one day he's basically
killed off enough planet said enough
people and again with silver surfers
role in relation to previously being The
Herald of Galactus and the fact that
he's rebelled he's basically trying to
preserve as many planets as he can from
the wrath of Galactus and so what
happens here is Deadpool and the Silver
Surfer engage in a fight with one
another and Deadpool is almost
immediately overpowered by the Silver
Star for the silver surfers able to hold
his own quite readily against Deadpool
and so as a result Deadpool admits
defeat he admits that he's been defeated
by the Silver Surfer before he takes off
he says he asked whether or not he can
have the surfboard of the Silver Surfer
and the Silver Surfer and by a look
simply just says no and so Deadpool
retreats back and so what we do is we
pick up with a Deadpool and some kind of
a facility and what's happening here is
it seems as though they're simply I
guess he's talking with a group of
people or somebody is talking and what
they're saying is that they're simply
trying to take it day by day they're
simply trying to try to go day by day
dealing with this I guess it's new role
that they play and what we learn is that
this is actually a group that's meeting
because they're all former heralds of
the lactis and so what Deadpool says is
that he was a Herald of Galactus and
that he's been clean for 90 days
with that being said we're gonna go
ahead and bring this video to an end I
hope you guys enjoyed it if you did let
me know and I will catch you guys later
peace
be sure to follow me on Twitter there
you can keep up with all the updates
from comics explained and talk to me
directly
you